I really couldn't think of much of an
opening joke for this I just thought I'd
bust out elf ears yeah I'm not gonna
keep those on this this whole time hey
everybody so on the recommendation of
one of my patreon supporters on on my
discord server because yes that is
available as a reward for the patreon I
caught the plugin early link in the
description so somebody had mentioned
that they watched the Dragon Prince on
Netflix and they recommended it to me
and I watched the first episode I was
like and then I ended up burning through
the rest of it over the next couple days
so yeah I liked it I liked it pretty
well a couple of bits of context before
I get into this I do know that it has
some of the same creative team from
Apatow the last airbender which and I
know I lose cred for this I have not
seen I have been meaning to see it
forever but like it's it's hard for me
to find the time that this edit has been
for a while says it just keeps getting
bumped down and and I'd end up doing
other stuff before it I will get around
to it one of these days I'm sure but the
main reason I bring that up is that it
means I'm not gonna compare it to Avatar
The Last Airbender which I hope is maybe
a little bit refreshing because at least
most of the reviews that I've seen are
all done by people who also saw avatar
so they could not help but make those
comparisons now that there's a problem
making those comers in but I don't have
them to make so I'll go spoiler free for
as long as I can as I tend to do I'll
give you a warning before I get into
spoilers so the premise is actually not
all that original it's a pretty standard
fantasy world setup you have kingdoms of
humans you have a world of elves they
don't like each other
the the elves hold a grudge against the
humans there's a backstory where there
was a dragon king that the humans
recently killed and that really put them
on the outs with the elves plus the
humans went an extra step and actually
destroyed the Dragons egg which means
that there wasn't someone - there isn't
another dragon to replace that that's
your titular dragon Prince that's you
know it's it's an one thing for the
humans to have killed the dragon king
but they slayed the unborn dragon Prince
and that's really set everything off I'm
going into a bad place but it's it's not
it's not a particularly particularly
unique world you've got elves you got
humans they don't like each other
fantasy kingdoms you know coming to a
head pretty basic what works is in the
fine detail specifically the I would say
the main strength of this show so far
are the characters because they're great
there are a lot of fun and the pacing
it's really well paced I will make a
comparison as far as the pacing
specifically ghosts the show that it
reminded me of is the anime series
escaflowne which is one of my favorite
anime shows and part of what I love
about that is how well it's paced it's
really tough when you do a continuous
story over a while to find ways to
divert the characters from what is
they're doing or have them get installed
or have you know their goal shift
without it feeling like continual
stalling tactics I mean to make a video
game comparison it's the difference
between having the quests sort of shift
and change what it is they need to
accomplish but their core goal you know
and that might even change as it goes on
if the difference between that and just
having a singular goal that never
changes and just loading them down the
side quests and it doesn't do that it
keeps it moving and it keeps it flowing
and it keeps it's well paced in that way
the characters are great the characters
were initially what hooked me in because
like said the first episode I was like
this not the characters I'm liking these
characters so
some of the things I like about them
we've got our three primary characters
so we have a couple of human princes
named Callum and ezrin Callum being a
little bit older kind of a young teen
you've got Aaron who's I don't know he's
maybe nine ish eight nine could be seven
I can't really tell live animated young
characters how old they're supposed to
be a lot of the time but then you've
also got an elf character and alpha
Sasson by the name of raela and those
are your three primary characters but
mmm those three that they're all good
Callum is he's interesting because they
manage to do the sort of awkward guy
thing yet awkward young guy he's you
know a little bit goofy he's really kind
of out of sorts without irritating me
and without making me cringe because
awkwardness humour embarrassment humour
which frequently comes out of that
I don't like cringing at that like it
makes me deeply uncomfortable I really
hate it to be perfectly honest but they
managed to have an awkward character
without dipping heavily into cringy
humour which I greatly appreciate it
Ezrin is just sweet he's just a sweet
kid and yet doesn't come across as
cloyingly sweet he feels he feels real
like you know having a young kid of my
own like yeah yeah I mean he's maybe a
little more Zen than many kids I know
but he's not that weird pretentious you
know old beyond his years nonsense
and then raela raela is just uh yeah how
do we go there raela is just so
frustrated with life and and she and
she's a lot of fun and she also gets a
lot of the better action scenes now
these three characters they're great
none of them are my favourite character
though my favorite character is bait
bait his ezrin's pet he is what's called
the glow toad he
he is a bulldog and lizard form is what
he is which is why I love him so much
are you I used to have a bulldog a while
back I think they are the the cutest
things ever and they like nobody can
give you side I like a bulldog and give
you side I and the and I just oh he's
great I know I'm not the only one who
loves him because from what I could tell
Hot Topic has already sold out of the
plushies of this guy and like shows only
been out for like a week as of my
recording so yeah baits the best so some
of the other characters are I
particularly enjoyed there's Viren who
is an advisor to the human king whose
hair oh and yeah they have an
interesting relationship that's pretty
good I love viren's kids though it's
Klaudia and Soren and they are they are
yet you know what it is they feel like
they stepped out of Brooklyn nine-nine
cuz Soren is you know he's this I don't
know if he actually is the captain of
guard but he's that kind of role and
he's very into you know how buff and in
shape and muscular he is you know he's
he's doing you know bends and lunges and
like you have my full attention and then
Claudia who's a mage is just I don't
even know how to describe Claudia she is
just she's maybe a slightly more focused
Luna Lovegood in a way like she's a
she's got a little bit clearer thought
process but that a little bit of that
randomness to a certain extent I really
enjoy them quite a bit
Amaya is another highlight Amaya is is
interesting because Amaya is deaf and
that is something that simply is like
there isn't extra attention drawn to its
uses sign language to communicate and
when doing so with someone who doesn't
know sign language she has a translator
who says it for her and it's just there
it's just an element of the character
and she actually has a handful
scenes where she does sign language and
you know just someone who understands it
we don't get a translation on it it just
happens and it feels nice and organic
it's actually a pretty dang diverse cast
overall in a very unassuming fashion so
like the King King hero had has dark
skin and as a result Ezrin the younger
Prince does as well
Callum the older Prince does not because
he's actually the stepson and
stepbrother
or I guess half brother half brother to
ezrin stepson of Harrow but you you've
got those in there and there are others
as well it's a it's it's just nice that
it is completely unremarked upon that's
what I really like and really enjoy
about it as an element it is remarkable
for being unremarkable love it
I think I'm gonna need to start no no I
can't I can talk about sort of my one
major sticking point with it and that's
the animation itself the designs are
solid but they're the animation gets
choppy it gets bad honestly so to use a
basically there are times where you can
tell there are frames missing which is
weird because with the technique that
they're actually using to animate this I
don't think that's a natural occurrence
I think they almost have to do that on
purpose I don't know that for certain
but the sis's isn't hand-drawn animation
it feels all the weirder now I'm used to
a certain amount of animation fluidity
not being consistent so like an animated
film that I love where that's very
evident is the last unicorn and the last
unicorn has a number of scenes where you
can tell they had fewer frames of
animation for this but then they have
some scenes like like the Red Bull
chasing the Unicorn where they brought
it up to the highest level of flew of
fluidity the most animation frames that
they could afford to do
and it looks smoother but you know so I
can I can handle that I can get used to
that but it was the the degree of how
jagged and stuttery the animation gets
during slower quieter usually dialogue
scenes compared to how smooth it is
during more intense and action-oriented
seas it's a big gap it's not a minor
thing to overlook it's a it's really
noticeable and it was jarring even up
until the last episode of this first
season it was jarring I like I stopped
getting annoyed by it but I never
stopped noticing it whenever it happened
so yeah that's like if anyone told me
that they'd watch the first episode and
they're like it's hurting my eyes
because it's it's not consistent like I
I get it so you know be be aware of that
but I think I'm gonna have to get into
spoilers a little bit more for anything
else that I'm gonna talk about and also
to get to some of my more nitpicky
issues but I really like this it goes
quick it's only nine episodes there are
like 25 minutes of pop you could give
you've got an empty day you can burn
through this in one sitting
really so I do recommend it if if you
like and adventurous entertaining a fun
at often light-hearted but with a with a
sense of weight and stakes storytelling
in animation
yeah go for it so getting it spoilers
now some of the directions some of the
characters went in was disappointing and
mainly I'm thinking about Viren for that
because why what I liked is once I
realized probably by I had my first
inkling and maybe episode 2 and by
episode 3 am i ya deaf
Veeran was gonna become the N tag the
functional antagonist of the story and
what I liked initially was that there
was a sense of depth to him and you know
you had his interactions with the king
where he felt hurt at the fact that the
king was doubting him and questioning
his motives and all these other things
but then once he kind of gets control he
became much more generic evil Vizier
style villain and I found that really
disappointing and on a personal level it
kind of irritates me that he kept
basically referring to himself as a
pragmatist and I'll just touch on this
quickly that annoys me because I feel
like whenever a character describes as a
pragmatist in entertainment it's that's
always as a negative or they are in some
way not a good person they were villain
they're an antagonist and as someone who
prides himself on being pragmatic
but not being pragmatic without you know
humanity and empathy at least I tried it
maintaining that as well you know seeing
seeing that this is like great is how
would people think pragmatists are
because God's sakes this guy's just a
dick and he's not a pragmatist either
he's doing things that are way way more
trouble than they're worth he's a
selfish prick who calls himself
pragmatist too to justify what he's
doing yeah yeah so I mean there's room
to add more depth to him but I feel like
he he was the one character who became
shallower as the series went on so that
was disappointing but I really did like
that again with his kids with Claudia
Mizoram when it became clear that they
were going to be they were gonna factor
in as antagonists that they they didn't
lose their depth and well I say depth
saurons kind of shallow by design but
like in a fun way so like I liked that
that was maintained I like in general
that
from Viren who I guess ain't kind of
goes off the deep end a little bit I
like that
you can't tell upon first encountering a
character whether or not he's going to
be an ally to our protagonist or a
hindrance so like take for example the
guy fighting in the square who had the
the Sun dagger thing that was totally
the kind of introduction you'd expect
from somebody who would tag along with
them or at least for a little bit help
them out and he just wasn't that you
know so his in how he panned out it
wasn't so much it wasn't to the degree
that I call it a subversion but you
can't call characters immediately and
even if you get a sense of well they'd
normally be an ally but they may not be
in this situation because of the
circumstances and people like Amaya fall
into that so I like not being able to
know right off the bat immediately good
guy bad guy and that's part of my
disappointment with Viren because I like
I feel like he's the only one who
sharply fell into a camp on that
everyone else are just they're they're
people they're people with flaws and
motivations and they're clashing and
Viren I got to get off that topic I'm
trying to think if there was anything
else of a particularly oh um the tail
end the last couple of episodes didn't
hold my interest quite as well but I
think it was because I really enjoyed
these characters in the in the civilized
world I'd liked I liked these characters
interacting with each other and by the
last couple of episodes I felt like we
just had really isolated pockets you had
Sauron and Claudia you know off on their
thing to do the spell you had the main
group trying to get up this mountain
you had Viren sending a my of like
everybody felt very isolated and I sort
of lost the connections between them
which was a big part of what I had
enjoyed previously was seeing how those
connections got strained and how it
caused characters to do what they did
when the pressure was put on and you
know these relationships really got
tested but when they became as sort of
isolated as they were by then it wasn't
quite as engaging still solid it ends on
a good note I'll be really curious to
see the next season oh one other thing
totally gonna call this right now that
the Kings in the bird like I'm not the
only one who's like you would duh
but I didn't figure that out immediately
because but I knew when Viren came out
of there after his whole conversation
with the King I'm like okay something's
up I just gonna figure out what it is
the Kings in the bird that's that's
what's going on I think I will wrap it
up there yeah it was a good job I know I
had nitpicks and I had things that I
complained about but you know I
complained I complained out of love I
mean I really do I I can enjoy the heck
out of something but I'm not gonna call
it perfect if it's not and there are
little things here and there but I
really enjoyed this I had a lot of fun
the characters are terrific
I really love spending time with these
characters and I look forward to getting
able to do more of that down the line
and I'm also gonna keep an eye out for
when um bait plushies go back on sale
because oh my God he's so really cute
that'll wrap it up folks the dragon
prints have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
oh let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff you can do there's
buttons and there's links I already plug
the patreon so I won't do it again
although didn't by mentioning it didn't
I kind of do it again forget it in any
case folks you're the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]